hello Christopher it is an absolute joy
to speak to you about this but um
in my hand because I've just been like
gripping my face
what was going on on screen I mean is
that joke
that is job one yes the whole idea is
that you know you only use the edge of
your seat yes that's what we that's what
we aim for I mean it literally uh seed
after Seas
but you guys do it thank you day one of
filming you're leaving man drives the
most cycle off a clear you have to watch
him do this seven times yes
eight times what goes through your head
um we have a saying on these movies now
this is a terrible idea when do we start
uh we did not
if if we knew what would go into it a
lot of times we would probably not
interced it we talk ourselves into
things and then and then we're committed
you just have to go through it and
when he's on that ramp once you call
action there's really nothing you can do
until it's over every few stars that
would put themselves
yeah yeah I mean as well the thing about
the mission impossible films is how do
you kind of trump the last one with each
thing I mean this is a two-parter are
you saying that the second part's gonna
be even bigger than this absolutely yes
how much fun do you have as a director
working on this I mean do you have all
of the sort of toys to play with it well
you I I never expected to to be a
director of action film so I certainly
never different perspective of direct
core Mission Impossible movies I'm here
to result of just going through the door
that opened taking an opportunity and
and building on it taking all the
knowledge that we've acquired from all
the previous films not just Mission but
top gun Maverick as of tomorrow putting
it towards this movie and you find
yourself standing on a cliff in Norway
talking about
your actor driving a motorcycle off the
it's a bit surreal it's a bit strange
but we just we're just grateful for the
opportunity of course the other big
thing that you had to contend with for
this was covered locked Downs as well I
mean in that respect was this one of the
most challenging films for you without
question and a lot of what you know we
were were supposed to start in February
of 2020 and Venice closed down two days
before we were supposed to start
shooting so we were there at Ground Zero
and uh and everything that happened
after that was essentially
reigniting the industry and figuring out
what those protocols would be and how to
make a movie in those conditions and our
team was on The Cutting Edge of it they
really Rose to the occasion it really is
I gotta say it's the best it's the best
crew in the world they're truly
extraordinary that's what makes it all
the more incredible that you managed to
pull this off during that Central
Station yeah when you watch that airport
scene and you realize that was shot in
the height of
shot in the height of coven all that
background all of that was all done
safely it was all done with covert
protocols and unfortunately everybody
came out safe
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you thank you for coming
that's okay
[Music]
hello I'm sorry
hey what's your name
thank you
because you
know
what an extraordinary film you guys have
meant it made it so so stressful to
watch some of these scenes and your
character in many ways contributes to a
huge amount of the action and the stress
that the audiences feel to to make this
to have this role I mean to throw
punches at Tom Cruise to him
it's a it's a dream time
oh that's a beautiful like um uh how do
you say frozen slip right I'm gonna I'm
gonna say that from now on now uh it's a
beautiful dream come true come true come
true same uh anyway it was my dream to
be a part of Mission Impossible
um I used to train years ago do strength
training fight training with a friend
called Jessa mugello who's a martial
artist and sometimes in my schedule in
my phone I would write instead of
training or stunt training or martial
arts training I would write Mission
Impossible because you know to try to
manifest it and it happened
so the the other impressive thing about
this is you guys managed to pull this
off during code with lockdowns yeah did
that in itself feel like a feat uh I
mean it feels amazing to be back here I
remember you know uh traveling to
different different countries and then
coming back here and having to
quarantine because we used to have to do
that back then you know so we stayed a
long time here and um and I feel very
grateful to be back here if you were a
fan of the franchise then we were too
daunted but Tom Cruise is there right in
front of you you're told to
yeah I mean
Lisa gentleman he would never hurt a
woman you know so but I wanted to really
I wanted it to really look real so I was
like yeah let's go for it and you know
we're like just like you know like
really excited to do this fight and uh
it was very technical a lot of training
a lot of bruises a lot of sweats but you
know it was all worth it
crazy how much Tom Cruise throws himself
into baseballs as well
it's amazing to watch him work you know
sometimes I would just go to set just to
to watch him and to watch him move my q
and even the rest of the cast you know I
was like almost like an audience member
within the movie you know it's a
brilliant role you have and
congratulations thank you so much
I love you yeah
[Music]
absolutely
um
I mean the thing that Thomas
really good
[Music]
at the moment it gets that point you put
them in a dangerous situation and the
you know the states are so much higher
so that's always the secret ingredient I
think I mean yeah
you know but I mean when we go out when
we're working we tend to go and do
something really fun like go-karts
um but I mean dinners it's usually
dinners it's like a family dinner
everyone who comes around
the table it's
quite evening it's obviously difficult
to go out when you talk because
everybody wants to be so usually like a
little kind of
kind of homely affair s
yes it is although it doesn't really
feel like the good thing I think they
nailed with this is that when you get to
the end of part one it doesn't feel like
oh I want no I won part two now you know
it finishes it hasn't
and also you couldn't possibly sit
through as much tension and Stakes again
for any amount of time they're having a
minor heart attack so it kind of feels
like yeah I can take a break for 12
months before the next one comes up yeah
it's a nascent technology you know
nobody really understands understand it
or
are they slightly overestimate
sentence
but it could be an amazing thing for us
in terms of technology in terms of space
travel medicine environment protection I
think in art it you know art is a human
thing art is the expression of human
emotions interpreted into the abstract
when it gets its own feelings then it
can makes them out of its own but you
know stay out of us
this
film I have seen it in a long long time
working on it no I can imagine
um look Cinema needs a film like this
audience numbers are down by a third
level yeah
it is vital you know that's something
that Tom considers a sort of existential
threat you know the idea that Cinema as
we know it might sort of vanish it
shouldn't it can't it's important that
it doesn't not just because it's
entertaining or because you know we're
seeing things on a big screen but this
is a moment when when a lot of people
who don't know each other get together
and share something in this day and age
when we're all on our phones the whole
time we're so insular we're so isolated
Cinema is a really really important
social kind of convention you know it's
a tribe and we can't disband that tribe
I'm talking about theater as well
anytime we're all together and we don't
know who's in the audience whose
political views whose kind of thoughts
on anything and yet we all share that
moment you know and I I genuinely
believe in its importance as part of our
society so yes I think people should
come and see this film in the cinema but
also I guess at a cost of living time
value for money is important true yeah
yeah you wanna you wanna come out and
make sure that you get a bang for your
buck and there is a lot of bang in this
film believe me so um yeah and also
what's great about this film is that it
you know it runs slightly longer I think
than the last one but it feels shorter
than some one hour films I've watched
you know what I mean and by the end of
it you feel so stated so kind of like
you'll just walk out of there thinking
that was money well spent you know
Cruise does the vast majority of the
action in this he got quiet a few good
action scenes I get the I get the best
part of this because I'm part of those
scenes but I'm always kind of guiding
him around so I send him up the mountain
and I kind of like I'm the one that's
looking after him when he's running
about I don't have to do the jumping
after hanging on to you know the
dangerous things frustratingly we can't
go into too much detail but the airport
scene it's a real heart racing scene
yeah that's that was a really fun scene
to do and there's a lot of emotion in
this as well you know obviously that
that thing that Benjy's dealing with is
sort of also trying to get to know him
as a person which is a very weird thing
to happen we're being told to wrap up
but one of the themes as well is is
friendship your friendship with Tom now
has lasted quite a few years yeah yeah
it's sort of strange to see how the
franchises change and how your
relationships yeah I mean you get to
know Tom quite quickly he wears his
heart on his sleeve you know it's not
like he's a mystery or anything when you
get when you finally get to him through
all the kind of Madness and speculation
and mystery that surrounds him there's a
guy in the middle of it is just very
passionate about his job he's incredibly
generous to everyone around him you know
he's a he's a
he's a really inspiring guy I mean I
love his passion I love how he cares so
much about making movies that he will
literally risk his life to to get the
best thing he can you know
um I love him you know he's a good guy
people will love watching this it's
brilliant thank you so much very nice to
meet you thank you
[Music]
hello thank you so much for talking to
us Katie thank you very nice to meet you
right have you seen it I have seen it
how about that I got pins and leaders
for my fans I was stopped moving
I hope the fans have as much fun
watching it as we
making it honestly Katie I I hope so I
think they will yeah look when you work
with a star like Tom Cruise there's very
few people that are up for doing the
level of sort of involvement that he
does and stands putting his neck on the
line and what have you
um yeah
well yeah this is our second picture
together and we did Days of Thunder Over
30 30 years ago and you know he's the
same guy he's he's so incredibly focused
you know he's a wonderful human being to
start with but he's so focused so
dedicated to his art and uh he's a
brilliant actor as you know he's in a
brilliant stunt man probably the
greatest stunt man that ever lived let's
face it and a brilliant producer so you
know he wears all these hats really well
and there's a reason he's the biggest
movie star on the planet you know and I
told him that we're back in Florida and
you know 30 some odd years ago
credit
s
um we're at a time where there's a cost
of living crisis Cinema audience numbers
are down by a third in this country yeah
yeah we need this yeah we do we sure do
well you know Tom's movies are events
yeah they're meant to be seen on the
biggest screen you can find
he wants the audience to feel the full
impact and the energy and the emotion of
his films and this one has it all as you
know Katie so it can't really be watched
you know on a small screen or on your
phone or you gotta get out there and
check it out on the biggest screen you
can find
it I enjoy I enjoyed it a lot thank you
my pleasure thank you thank you
negative
[Music]
thank you
French
um
[Music]
what a brilliantly stressful film you
have all created I mean welcome
doesn't it
I mean I feel like the luckiest person
in the world to be back in this to feel
the team collaboration the harm the
energy having to stay a bit in shape it
comes with so much in life Jim I mean
it's the best game it's the best job I'm
just lucky
um your relationship with Tom Cruise
this this is a film of one of the themes
is friendship as well it's that kind of
Throne over the time that you've known
him as well yeah and I think something
that we never discussed about Tom is the
fact that he's very good at stunts yes
and it is all
managed into
the minute you know particle detail of
safety but he also walked on to set and
we talk about character and he will go
why why am I feeling this why would I do
that why did this happen but if I do
this why I mean the breakdown of the Arc
of the character for all characters are
equally as important for him what a
professional as well I mean he comes to
an event like this signs every single
person
I have them on my like
the shittiness who do you not want to
work with I'm like Tom Cruise
yeah I'm just done no I love him I love
him I could aspire
I could aspire to be like 10 of him
could we all do with being 10 more tall
I think so ten percent more time that's
the T-shirt
um can I just talk very quickly about um
algorithms AI deep fakes and what
happened absolutely I'm a professional
I'm ridiculously exactly I know at all
Mensa means nothing to me
go on Tom Cruise himself has been a
victim of deep fake on many an occasions
as actors is it kind of mildly
terrifying that you're signing away all
these rights and you don't quite know
what's going on in their battles Now
isn't it I mean we have the writers the
director settle an agreement we're now
looking at maybe sag doing um a strike
there's many feelings about it I think
there are many issues that we need to
talk about and I think
it's hard isn't it do you put everything
in one for a potpourri of everything to
analyze and to dissect but I am scared I
I don't want AI to take over I also
believe that we live in a world where it
is active and where it will be merged
and you can't fight it it's there and it
is there to stay it is there to be
developed but maybe we can protect
ourselves with a percentage quote in
contracts maybe we don't have to sign a
way and people can't and are not allowed
to use our own identity and our voices
and our movements and our faces
Expressions the same for the writers you
know you can get AI to write it will it
have emotion will it have stamina is
that where we want to go even if we can
you're giving so much of yourself away
look for somebody who didn't say they
had internet intellectual thoughts
thank you
Escape
no no no no no no
no no
that's so amazing
foreign
thank you
sorry
[Music]
of course not I mean it's a it's a
visceral adrenalizing experience and so
much of it obviously is meticulously
planned out and designed the stunts are
all we trained for five months but when
you're there in the moment you're also
kind of wanting to search for and find
the thing that feels most alive so you
we are adrenalized as we're doing it and
we're we we know also the dangers
involved and you really have to sell
that as something that's terrifying and
at times it
it was scary it was
adrenalizing but I didn't I wasn't
scared because I felt very safe you know
the team the stunting behind Tom is
remarkable and his attention is detail
and care of making sure everyone's okay
at one point he looked at me he went
you're okay and I was like I don't know
I don't I don't even know at this stage
I don't know where I am what I'm doing I
just and he's like you have adrenal
fatigue and eating some chocolate and he
presented me with this beautiful box of
chocolate and he was like you need to
eat this and I was like yes I do and I
will in the name of my art I need Tom
Cruise in my life and this alone this is
impressive it got me going it's great
join as well is it is it better than any
gym being a part of this of course I
mean you're working I drift was drifting
with a race car driver for five months
doing unarmed combat sleight of hand
tricks working with mixed martial arts
kind of fight styles to find out where
Grace
where her her physicality was and we
wanted to make a similar and origin
story to Ethan in that she was a an
opportunist and I believe we kind of
learn on the job
so all of my training was kind of
working out how not just to be I didn't
want it to be cool slick you know sexy I
didn't want to do one thing I didn't
want her to be the Femme Fatale the ice
queen the orange I wanted her to
happening once because you know she in a
way is experiencing this the way the
audience is she's an outsider coming in
going what have I got myself into here
and she's making it up and she goes
along so I wanted the all the
physicalities I feel like it was
reflecting someone who was out of her
depth but they're going to give it a go
anyway well I am contractually obliged
not to give away too many details about
your character and what happens in the
film but are you the best dinner party
guest ever now this this Leatherman
that's sleight of hand magic that we
have
the best thing about it is learning
about being a put pocket so you can
plant things on people which is like
have it it's like basically equivalent
of someone holding holding your drink
for them while you go up and have fun
and then coming and they have no idea
and then you pick it off them at the end
of the night like it's uh you know it's
useful in crowds so I have to say
um but yeah and I think you know I've
learned so much about the whole film
process you know and
that both McHugh and Tom really
demystify the filmmaking process because
they're so inclusive in it and they are
always studying film and their students
themselves and they always want to know
what is the kind of Cutting Edge
technology or what is that thing that's
living in the cultural Consciousness the
audiences are going to relate to and
attach themselves to and feel connected
to
it this is an absolute Gem of a film if
you would like to plant some chocolate
in my pocket with the ordinary family
pocket little little treat that you
check your pockets later congratulations
thank you very much
thank you
Too Short then into just him and then
back to me at the end all right two shot
then into him and then back to him
[Music]
thank you
you know what I'm actually doing
something prepared so much
foreign
[Music]
before
I really have no idea
[Music]
people you've inspired me to get back so
thank you so much
foreign
[Music]
and I'm joined now by the man of the
hour Mr Tom Cruise look Tom I was so
unbelievably stressed watching this film
I got pins and needles because I was
punching my face or clutching the chair
is that job done is this what you want
you know anybody here that take it off
take it off I want you I want you to
just have a great summer experience with
this film The thing about these films is
you watch one and you think they're not
going to be able to Trump the next I
mean how do you do this how do you
Workshop this you know it's McHugh and I
and we just constantly push each other
never rest on your laurels after every
film that we have and tonight I'll
probably say to him again when it's done
when I turn around and go we could do
better you know that's how I feel about
about everything that I do tell us about
day one of shooting when you get on a
motorcycle go open the cliff yes
thing they've done six seconds before
you might hit the ground why because you
even have time to question what you're
doing you know there's honestly there's
some when I train there's so much going
on that time expands
when I'm dropping at six seconds
feels longer you know it feels short and
long so there's there's there's time to
think about things and so much is
happening I've got the helicopter coming
across I have a drone going this way and
going off and making sure that I don't
open that I depart from the from the
motorcycle that I don't open too soon
because I have to fall long enough so
that's I'm holding out as long as I can
before I open that parachute
now also the other big thing you had to
contend with for this was covered and we
know that you followed the rules our
government weren't quite as good as
doing that is that annoying and how how
hard was it for you to contend you know
it's a beautiful moment to be able to
share hello it's a beautiful moment to
be able to share with the crew the film
that they all made during that time
period with their families so we had a
big uh big wonderful evening last night
with them it was it was quite a moment
I'm very proud of everyone what they did
to get through that and you know when
you look at the films see what we all
accomplished together it meant even more
that you know I just never I don't take
anything for granted making these films
and particularly during that time period
I'm just very proud of what we all did
together you're being dragged away give
us a little tease about part two
importantly expect
it's called Mission Impossible it's got
dead racket in part two I can't
I it's a little bit you said a little
cheese okay
I can't you know it's gonna be an epic
adventure
absolutely stunning thank you very
thank you Tom Cruise there the film
Mission Impossible dead reckoning coming
out on July the 10th what amount the
stunts are quite frankly incredible to
watch
[Music]
um
I don't know
[Music]
questions